huh specialists the old money
overachievers of the nen world a
lifestyle that most of us will likely
never get to experience no matter how
hard we work however as a consolation
prize each and every one of you are
capable of subscribing to the new order
view and thus receiving regular Hunt
under content uploaded straight into
your YouTube feed just don't tell the
specialist okay it'll be our little
secret
hello and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are going to be concluding
our journey through the realm of the six
basic aura typings of hunt hunter with
quite probably the most intriguing
exploration that nen has to offer being
the art of specialization and to put it
very basically a specialist use of Nan
is simply an invocation that cannot be
classified into the other five areas
being enhancement transmutation
manipulation conjuration and omission
which makes specialization very very
vague but it also provides the most
potential for some truly insane
abilities but very importantly
specialization is the only nanka degree
that cannot be accessed by those with
other natural affinities so for example
even if you were a conjurer or a
manipulator which are right next to the
specialist on the nen ring then even
though they are only one place removed
this invocation is completely
inaccessible to them and in order to use
specialist nen you need to be a natural
specialist the existence of which seems
to be quite rare in the world of hunt on
top that isn't to say that all hope is
lost though intriguingly enough unlike
every other area of Nan it is indeed
possible for a user to become a
specialist later in life with some form
of nen evolution or via another unknown
factor and the greatest example we have
of this would come in the form of crop
oka whose nan typing actually changes
from conjurer to specialist whenever he
activates his scholar dyes and karappa
go is well placed to access the switch
because Condor is a manipulator z'
allegedly have the highest chance of
becoming a specialist while the enhancer
would have the lowest chance but as such
specialists hold many key advantages in
the min world the first of which being
that they can afford to be a bit more
loose with the revelation of their
general typing and this is because it
doesn't actually do anybody a whole lot
of good to discover that you are a
specialist it still leaves them with a
gigantic question mark as if they knew
nothing about you at all and you might
make the argument that it tells
opponents valuable information about
one's placement on the nen ring and that
a specialist for example would be highly
unlikely to be using enhancement
techniques because it would be their
exact opposite but that's not
necessarily true either because your
specialist
could be something that provides an
enhancement effect so simply identifying
a specialist is borderline useless there
are still so many questions and we'll
briefly go into crop pika again for an
example of this business
his specialist ability is known as
Emperor time which while invoked gives
him 100% proficiency in each nen
category meaning that even as a
specialist crop oka can use enhancement
on the same level as that of a natural
enhancer a factor that greatly confused
the Phantom troops of again who was a
natural enhancer himself but that's the
really painful thing to remember about
specialists for all intents and purposes
they can do almost literally anything
which makes predicting them nigh on
impossible unless you have an intimate
familiarity with the specialist in
question before we dive into more of the
user so let's also address Hisoka semi
reliable personality test in which he
identifies specialists as independent
and charismatic but in a very specific
way according to the magician because
apparently they have natural charisma
that draws others but they will refrain
from becoming too close to these people
and generally like to keep their
thoughts to themselves and look off the
top of my head I can definitely think of
at least four specialists that this
accurately depicts there's also a
handful that it certainly does not but
for a discussion regarding
specialization I don't think we can
really start anywhere else except with
the leader of the Phantom troop Crowell
Lucifer who is probably the most
notorious specialist in the series and I
guess I should preface this by saying
it's not entirely clear how specialist
abilities are generated in the same way
that other affinities allow for
technical explanations of for example
with conjuration we know that a user has
to undergo image training in order to
form their eventual hot soup but with
specialists it's much more of a gray
area and it would seem as if abilities
are manifested almost entirely by raw
desire and/or need for them and in
Kerala's case that would form skill
hunter he delightful little book that
allows him to quite literally steal the
nen abilities of others providing krolow
of course fulfills four criteria
including seeing the ability in question
having his target answer an inquiry
about the ability as well as having them
touch the handprint on the cover of the
book and finally all of this needs to be
accomplished within an hour
it's an incredible and almost impossible
set of restrictions but when implemented
correctly it results in a nifty ability
and nothing is off-limits to Crowell oh
he can even steal other specialist
abilities as well and this would be the
exact action he took in the orc new city
art by targeting another specialist by
the name of neon
who had a fascinating Honsou known as
lovely ghostwriter and this is quite
probably one of the greater examples of
specialization because it's such a
bizarre ability basically it allows neon
to predict the future through cryptic
poetry or more accurately not neon
herself but the manifested presence of
what looks to be an n beast and this
present scent manipulates neons arm to
write a poem in terms of restrictions
this does require the target of the
prophecy to write their full name date
of birth and blood type on the same
piece of paper intended for the poem and
either the physical presence of the
target or a photo of them so it would
appear to be something of a consensual
activation like neon can't just predict
anybody's future that she wishes the
target definitely has to want this to
happen as well in addition to this neon
can only predict roughly a month into
the future with each verse representing
one week and most importantly neon
cannot predict her own future although
in this regard krolow is quite tricky in
circumventing this by having neon
predict his future before he stole the
lovely ghostwriter ability but this is
specialization incarnate there are
certain parts of nan construction one
can identify such as conjuring than an
Beast and having it manipulate you which
is not unheard of actually but by and
large there is just no formula for or a
usage that can result in an ability like
this from the basic typings
for more of this lower let's continue
with the phantom troop because they have
an often forgotten second specialist on
their team being Park gue Noda and she
has a pretty insane mind reading style
ability known as psychometry and to
activated she just needs be in physical
contact with her target and then ask
some specific questions and apparently
she can also use this to extract
memories as well plastic can also be
applied to physical objects using her
power to see into the recent past have
said object although it's never
specifically stated what that limit is
but it's another one of those esoteric
abilities taking advantage of an aspect
not accessible by basic or mechanisms
but that's not even all because park uno
de also has a secondary Honsou known as
memory bomb and here Park Geun Oda can
share her own memories by seemingly
infusing them in turn in bullets and
then firing them directly into the heads
of her targets which sounds quite
violent but is ever so effective very
interestingly though she can also share
the memories of others that she has
extracted but if she shoots a target
with their own memory then that memory
is simply erased which I guess makes
memory returns somewhat impossible which
is
very intriguing but for another
particularly famous case of
specialization though we now turn to
Nephi Pete oh and Pete Oh is an
especially fun case due to their nature
of being a chimera ant world guard born
with a godly reservoir of aura because
this has given Pete Oh license to do
effectively anything that they want
usually or is a substance be preserved
and used very efficiently one needs to
think extraordinarily carefully or be
very much in need to manifest it into a
Honsou but with Pete oh they just had
the freedom to turn whatever when they
had into an ability and one such example
would be dr. Blythe and then beasts
created for the purpose of healing or
well not healing but more accurately
performing very specific and
knowledgeable surgery and in order to
achieve something as potent Peto is not
allowed to use any other known ability
be it a hawk sue or some other basic
invocation whilst dr. Blythe is active
and the conjurer giant doll also cannot
move from the spot where it was summoned
until the job is done
but Vito also created two more
specialists Honsou one of which being
the the bigger clown thing that controls
corpses and another known as terpsichore
ax which was designed to control the
body of Peter themselves and to allow
Peter to push past the natural limits
however with these two latter hearts ooh
I should note that they are not
necessarily specialists implications
because both of them could be explained
as a combination of manipulation
conjuration and or omission but it is
still completely unknown particularly in
the case of top-scorer but look there is
a surprising amount of specialist
chimera and so and we would be remiss
not to mention that King Mero M is
indeed one of them now marijuana often
gets mistaken as an enhancer by certain
factions of the fan base because to be
fair he doesn't really engage in much of
the world of nirn because his existence
lies beyond such trivial concepts of
power and he really only uses the more
basic techniques attached to the art
form but he is a specialist and that
could be seen in his one natural Honsou
known as aura synthesis which gives him
the ability to devour an end users or
parts of known users gathering more aura
for himself and even acquiring the
abilities of those known users but
really the fact that marijuana is a
specialist only goes to further terrify
me when it comes to his character
because that affinity does basically
make him a God who could have done quite
literally anything he wanted he was just
never pushed far enough into developing
more Honsou because I suppose this ball
just did not have the power to require
such an endeavor here's one that
surprises me there because the mighty
lion Li
would also be an example of a specialist
and he holds kind of like a budget
version of crawler skill hunter which in
this case is called rental bot so as the
name implies rather than stealing this
allows Leo to borrowing an ability after
meeting two conditions
firstly he has to witness the ability
justice with Corolla and secondly he
needs to do the owner of said ability of
favor and then have them confirm that
general concept of debt which records an
IOU for every successful favor
accomplished Leo can then call in these
IR use and use the ability for an hour
for each higher you during which time
the original owner cannot access their
ability so yeah it's a much less
effective skill hunter especially
because it doesn't allow layout to
become too familiar with his new powers
but it is significantly easier to invoke
which is a great example of the
wonderful balance of nem and you know
what I have one more special stand for
you now being Marin who has a two-tier
Honsou collection going on here with
perfect plan which grants him
invisibility whilst holding his breath
not just that though but it also
essentially erases any trace of male
Iran's presence to those around him and
in fact he even becomes undetectable by
n although you can still track Miller on
by smells stinky ant but he can also
extend the effect of perfect plan to a
friend via the use of God's accomplice
which just requires physical contact
with another living being on object I
guess and as for limitations beyond
holding his breath it is implied that he
may need to form a bond with his
accomplice prior to performing this
han-soo and also that the partner may
need to agree in order for it to work
that does not confirm though it's just
implied so Mel Iran has a pretty great
thing going for him here though not
wildly powerful in combative situations
but the perfect utility ability which is
where most specialist class users land
really cool and unexpected powers that
open up a whole new world of options for
nen use but our final specialist on
today's menu will come from longer
events and it is 4th Prince radnik a
rapidly developing natural nan genius
who has very much subconsciously
developed an incredible heart soo called
peril or future and if you're familiar
at all with JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
this ability is basically King Crimson
but much more balanced and to be honest
far far better explained although it is
a very clear reference to that
particular trader stand and look without
going too deeply into it because it
requires diagrams and lots of
explanation sir I Nick can see 10
seconds into the future but this vision
runs parallel to reality so the events
are happening in real time that's right
visions on ten seconds ahead the issue
is that he needs to be in the state of
zetsu to activated though making him
potentially completely defenseless to
anybody who can overcome his pre
cognition so he's a pretty scary dude
and he's also one of the individuals who
falls pretty perfectly into he soaked
his personality assessment people
gravitate towards his charisma which is
very dangerous because that is a trap
which generally results in surrounding
brutally murdering people for the sake
of his artistic endeavors to begin to
conclude specialization though there are
many abilities in this series which may
come under this category from users who
are not attributed to the specialist
class the primary example of that coming
to mind would be Biscay who is a natural
transmuter however her body
transformation can't actually be
explained by any of the basic name
categories and in fact due to how it
happens spawning from her hatred of her
natural form this is very much in line
with how specialist powers are developed
it happened entirely naturally from raw
desire so while it is incredibly
unlikely Biscay may be another example
of a person who became a specialist
later in life however she is officially
labeled as a transmuter and in fact to
this end you could also probably say the
same thing about groans transformation
this was a desperate situation in which
he may very well have developed
specialists meant to activate however I
suppose it could also be enhancement
because we have seen examples of
enhancement like this adieu focused
purely on physical growth and then
buffing like bills Eragon so this could
just be a pretty extreme example of that
another one that piques my interest
there would be palms Siberia because two
of her abilities being wink blue and
moment clairvoyance once again can't
really be explained by the five basic
typings and their results very much full
in line with specialist abilities so
there's a lot of interesting stuff to
explore here with specialization and a
great degree of mystery that even in
this late stage of hunt Tonto still
surrounds it however what I will say is
that there has never been a moment in
the series where a specialist has been
introduced and it did not provide an
incredible sense of hype with great
trepidation specialists are by far the
most versatile and potentially
devastating end users because they have
no restrictions placed on their power
with the exception of our quantity and
as such should a particularly powerful
and driven person be bestowed with the
specialist affinity well then that
creates some of hunter hunters most
profound and memorable world figures
what do you guys think please to leave
your thoughts in the comments below
we'll even join my discord server and if
you
invisible hunt onto content then please
to go and check out some of my other
videos we'll even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt and Glory
delivered straight until YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new old
review and I'll see you next time